This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全却必须坦诚的对话，但你们是在和一个懂得如何操作的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少人披着一身铠甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它，请聆听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理清我们是如何撑过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I want to just thank all of you who have ordered or pre-ordered my book. This last week has been off the charts. The support has been so overwhelming. If you don't already know my first book, Person in Progress, a roadmap to the psychology of your 20s, came out this week. And I am just, I'm, well, obviously, I'm speechless. I'm so grateful for this community and I'm so grateful for you guys and for the support you've shown me. Some of you have even
欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析20多岁时的心理学。在开始之前，我只想感谢所有订购或预订了我书的朋友们。过去这一周简直太火爆了。大家的支援让我感到无比震撼。如果你还不知道我的第一本新书《成长中的人：通往20多岁心理学的路线图》（Person in Progress, a roadmap to the psychology of your 20s）已于本周上市。而我简直，我，很显然，我已经说不出话来了。我非常感激这个社群，非常感激你们大家以及你们对我的支持。你们中的一些人甚至
finished the book already, which is insane because it came out three days ago. And it just means so much to me. I had so much imposter syndrome going into this. I was catastrophizing every moment of every day, the negative reviews I was going to get. You know, how many people would say she's a terrible writer. She shouldn't have done this. I don't know. I just, I was my own worst enemy for a little bit there and yet I have been met with just a wall of positivity and love from you all. And gosh, it's made me feel really good about the world. It's made me feel really good about humanity and it's made me feel really good about myself. So thank you so much for providing me with that gift.
已经读完了这本书，这太疯狂了，因为它三天前才刚上市。这对我意义重大。在写这本书的过程中，我有过太多的冒名顶替综合征（imposter syndrome）。我每天每时每刻都在把事情灾难化，担心我会收到多少负面评价。你知道的，会有多少人说她是个糟糕的作家。她本不该做这件事。我不知道，我只是，有一段时间我简直成了自己最大的敌人，然而我却迎来了你们所有人铺天盖地的正面评价和爱意。天哪，这让我对这个世界感觉真的很好。这让我对人性感觉真的很好，也让我对自己感觉真的很好。所以非常感谢你们赐予我这份礼物。
I hope that I've provided you with a gift and that my book will help you, has helped you. It's fascinating, interesting, makes you feel less alone and that if you haven't already ordered it, you check it out. You can buy it anywhere. You buy books. Preferably your local bookstore. I don't make any more money from where you buy it. I just feel like at this time and this day and age, big corporations maybe need a little bit less of our money and shop local, shop your independent bookstore who will really appreciate that $20 sale and who you can have a nice chat with the person behind the counter and you can peruse and feel homely and cozy. That's kind of my preference.
我希望我也能回馈你们一份礼物，希望我的这本书能对你们有所帮助，已经帮助了你们。它引人入胜、有趣，能让你感觉不再那么孤单，如果你还没有订购的话，可以去看看。你可以在任何售书的地方买到它。最好是你的本地书店。你在哪里买书，我都不会多赚一分钱。我只是觉得在这个时代，大企业或许不需要我们那么多的钱，去本地买，去支持你的独立书店吧，他们会真心感激那20美元的销售额，你可以和柜台后的人愉快地聊天，你可以浏览书籍，感受家一般的温馨和舒适。这算是我的偏好。
But again, thank you so much, even for just, you know, listening to the podcast, for talking about the podcast with friends, talking about my book with your friends, checking it out on Goodreads, any of those things. It really means the world. But without further ado, let's stop babbling on about person in progress. And let's get into the episode. Now, I'm not proud to admit that this episode is inspired by a moment that happened to me the other day. And it involves a bicycle. So I was walking to my ceramics class,
但再次非常感谢，哪怕只是收听播客，和朋友谈论播客，和朋友谈论我的书，在Goodreads上查看它，或者任何诸如此类的事情。这真的意义重大。闲话少说，让我们停止对《成长中的人》的唠叨。让我们切入本集的正题。现在，我并不以此为荣，不得不承认这一集的灵感来自于前几天发生在我身上的一件事。它和一辆自行车有关。当时我正步行去上陶瓷课，
which you guys know I go to every single Wednesday, and I had my headphones on. I was playing the new Lord song, of course, and I was tuned in. My 14-year-old self was having a great time. And as I went to turn this corner, this cyclist rides past me and like brushes me, like brushes against my arm. And as she passes, she turns around. and makes this gesture to me like, look where you're going and she shakes her head and she rides off. But as she rides off, like she keeps looking back at me and keeps shaking her head, like looking very disapproving. And it kind of shocked me, but my second reaction was just rage.
你们都知道我每周三都会去上课，我戴着耳机。当然，我当时在放洛德（Lorde）的新歌，我完全沉浸其中。我那14岁的内心正玩得不亦乐乎。就在我转过这个街角时，一个骑自行车的人从我身边骑过，像擦着我一样，就像擦着我的胳膊一样。当她骑过去时，她转过身，
Like, how dare she be mad at me? I'm just listening to my music. She doesn't own the road, blah, blah, blah. And I was really mad. I was really upset. and immediately after that, I felt so gross. I felt this deep anger, evil, meanness in my bones. I was so mad at her.
做出那种示意我“看路”的手势，她摇了摇头，然后骑走了。但当她骑走时，她还是一直回头看我，一直摇着头，看起来非常不赞同。这让我有点震惊，但我的第二反应只有愤怒。
I kept thinking about it over and over again. And it just was weighing me down. And as I kept walking and I calmed down, I was like, wait a second, what the heck was that? Where did that come from? like why am I feeling so entitled and angry at this poor woman who I probably cut off like I wasn't paying attention and it kind of scared me my ego was so reactive that it clouded my judgment it made me think ill of this total stranger and honestly it put me in such a terrible mood for the rest of the
就像，她怎么敢生我的气？我只是在听音乐。这条路又不是她家的，巴拉巴拉。我真的很生气。我真的很沮丧，在那之后不久，我感到自己无比恶劣。我的骨子里感到了那种深深的愤怒、邪恶和卑劣。我太生她的气了。
day and for what it was just after this that I was like hmm I need to humble myself right now. It is time to sit back and reflect on what's going on here because that right there, that was ugly behavior. And it was really that instance that triggered me to start noticing some changes in myself recently and changes that I didn't like. It feels icky and hard to look at, but, you know, I've been more jealous recently. I've been more critical.
我脑子里一遍又一遍地想着这件事。这简直让我喘不过气来。随着我继续往前走，我冷静了下来，我想，等一下，这到底是什么鬼？这情绪是从哪儿来的？为什么我对这个可能被我挡了路的、可怜的女人怀有这么强烈的特权感和愤怒呢？（当时我根本没注意看路）这有点吓到我了。我的自我（ego）反应如此激烈，以至于它蒙蔽了我的判断力，让我对这个完全的陌生人产生了恶劣的想法，老实说，它让我剩下的时间里
I've been more defensive. I've been more argumentative. and because of how conscious I am of it, it really got me thinking about humility and why does the case that I had perhaps incidentally allowed my ego to kind of go off the rails? That's a hard thing to talk about and even saying that I'm wondering who out there is judging me, who out there is thinking differently of me, but something I always believe is that if you're experiencing something, someone else out there is also experiencing it. And hopefully my candor is beneficial to someone else who is noticing this weird entitlement in themselves that is causing them a lot of shame and that they want to change. Sometimes we do have to practice humility. Sometimes when our ego takes over, we do have to rein her in.
心情变得糟糕透顶。为了什么呢？正是在这之后，我心想，嗯，我现在必须放低姿态了。是时候坐下来反思一下到底发生了什么，因为刚才那种行为，真的很丑陋。正是这个实例触发了我最近开始注意到自己身上的一些变化，而且是我不喜欢的变化。这种感觉很恶心，也很难直面，但是，你知道的，我最近变得更有嫉妒心了。我变得更加挑剔。
So how exactly, and this is the question I've been asking myself, how exactly do we strike that healthy balance between being, proud of ourselves, knowing what we deserve, but not being prideful. How do we strike the balance of being confident, but not arrogant? That's really what I want to lay out for all of us today, including the real definition of ego, what ego looks like where it comes from, what pride looks like, the consequences of an inflated ego, and the six steps that I personally have been taking to bring me back to a humble, honest equilibrium and to make me a more pro-social better human, because whatever has been happening in my brain, in my body that has caused me
我变得更有防御性了。我变得更喜欢争辩了。正因为我对这一切有着清醒的认识，这让我开始思考谦逊，为什么我会无意中让我的自我（ego）有点彻底失控呢？这是一个很难启齿的话题，甚至在说出这句话的时候，我都在琢磨外面有谁在评判我，有谁在对我有不同的看法，但我始终坚信的一点是，如果你正在经历某事，外面也一定有其他人正在经历同样的感受。希望我的坦诚能对其他人有所帮助，他们可能也在自己身上注意到了这种奇怪的特权感，这给他们带来了巨大的羞耻感，并且他们希望做出改变。有时我们确实需要练习谦逊。有时当我们的自我占据主导时，我们确实需要勒住她的缰绳。
to respond this way to certain situations, I don't like it. But I also think that when you acknowledge parts of yourself that you don't particularly enjoy, you're also capable and you must change them or kind of submit, voluntarily submit yourself to suffering under the impression of your own thoughts and feelings that you don't take accountability for. So it's a bit more of a philosophical episode today, but I promise we also touch on some very important psychology. Without further ado, no judgment zone. Let's talk about humility. So before we get into it, we firstly need to talk about the various definitions of ego, because surprisingly, there is more than one. Most of us tend to
那么到底，这也是我一直在问自己的问题，我们究竟该如何在“为自己感到骄傲、清楚自己应得什么”与“不自大”之间找到健康的平衡？我们该如何在自信而不傲慢之间找到平衡？这正是我今天想为我们所有人和盘托出的内容，包括自我的真正定义、自我的外在表现及其来源、傲慢的外在表现、膨胀自我的后果，以及我个人一直在采取的六个步骤，这些步骤让我恢复到谦逊、诚实的平衡状态，并让我成为一个更具亲社会倾向、更好的人，因为无论我的大脑或身体里发生了什么导致我
think of ego as just our sense of self-confidence or our sense of self-worth. When our ego is inflated, we believe we possess more worth than others, which is not true. When our ego is deflated, we believe we possess less worth than others. It's also not true. All humans contain equal worth. Ego is about our perception of ourselves in comparison to others. Therefore, it's a subjective acknowledgement, it's subjective opinion, rather than an objective fact of who we are. So the first definition of ego that you are probably familiar with is pride, self-worth, self-confidence. It is often associated with entitlement, feeling like you deserve more than you have or than what others have. From a more psychological perspective, though, we want to turn to Freud's definition.
对某些情况做出这种反应，我都很不喜欢。但我也认为，当你承认自己身上那些你特别不喜欢的特质时，你同样有能力并且必须去改变它们，否则就是向痛苦妥协，甘愿受制于那些你没有承担责任的想法和感受。所以今天这期节目偏向哲学一些，但我向你们保证，我们也会触及一些非常重要的心理学知识。闲话少说，这是一个无评判区。我们来聊聊谦逊。所以在深入探讨之前，我们首先需要讨论自我的各种定义，因为令人惊讶的是，自我不止一个。我们大多数人倾向于
is really the one that first interrogated this idea of ego. Freud, of course, being the very famous Austrian psychoanalyst. And his idea of ego differed slightly to the definition that we currently uphold. Freud saw the ego as the part of the mind that mediates between our primal urges, our moral values, and reality. All of us, you and me, we have this impulsive desire to take, to do what we want to do, to be quite animal. We have these natural instincts of possession and desire. But we are also ruled by this very real moral system that is taught to us at a young age and which, yes, doesn't always get it right, but is what allows us to be civilized and respectful
将自我（ego）仅仅视为我们的自信心或自我价值感。当我们的自我膨胀时，我们相信自己比别人拥有更高的价值，这不是真的。当我们的自我受挫时，我们相信自己拥有的价值比别人低。这也是不真实的。所有人拥有的价值都是相等的。自我关乎我们相对于他人对自己的看法。因此，这是一种主观的认可，是一种主观的意见，而不是关于我们是谁的客观事实。所以你可能熟悉的自尊的第一层定义就是骄傲、自我价值感、自信。它通常与特权感联系在一起，觉得你应得的比你拥有的更多，或者比别人拥有的更多。然而，从更心理学的角度来看，我们想要转向弗洛伊德的定义。
to each other. It's things like, don't steal, don't make people feel bad about themselves, don't murder, don't be unkind. So when the part of us that is quite unruly gets too big, our ego becomes unbalanced and we behave in a way that makes us feel gross or uncaring or arrogant. Therefore, this part of us, it's called the id, needs taming, it needs humbling, so that the moral side and the id can sit in harmony. So that's the definition given by Freud. Ego is an unbalanced system within us where pride is allowed to take over. Let me give you another definition of ego that's not psychological, it's philosophical,
这才是真正最先审视这个自我概念的人。弗洛伊德，当然是那位非常著名的奥地利精神分析学家。他对自库的看法与我们目前坚持的定义略有不同。弗洛伊德将自我视为心灵中介于我们的原始冲动、道德价值观和现实之间的那部分。我们所有人，你和我，都有这种冲动的欲望去索取、去做我们想做的事、表现得很野性。我们有着占有和欲望的自然本能。但我们也受制于一套非常真实的、从小就被教导的道德系统，虽然这套系统确实并不总是正确的，但它正是让我们能够文明相处并相互尊重的
and it comes from Buddhism. So in Buddhism, ego is basically the source of suffering. Ego has us forget that we exist in a very vast flowing ecosystem with other living souls who all have their own intricacies, stories and worth, and our ego is the thing that puts us above everyone else in a very unnatural and harmful way. So there is an incredible article written by the mindful stoic that I was reading when I was exploring this topic that talks about the idea of anata or the no self, which is quite popular in Buddhism. Basically, this idea of the no self suggests that we are a combination of everything around us. We are constantly changing.
东西。诸如：不要偷窃，不要让别人感觉不好，不要谋杀，不要心存恶意。因此，当我们身上那些相当不受约束的部分变得太大时，我们的自我就会失衡，我们的行为就会让我们觉得自己很恶心、冷酷或傲慢。因此，我们身上的这部分，被称为本我（id），需要被驯服，需要被放低姿态，这样道德的一面和本我才能和谐共处。这就是弗洛伊德给出的定义。自我（ego）是我们体内一个失衡的系统，在这个系统中，傲慢得以占据主导。让我给你们提供自我的另一个定义，它不是心理学的，而是哲学的，
nothing makes us more special than anyone else. There is nothing that we do that we can ever take full credit for. We are basically just the world experiencing itself. And when we respect that principle, our attachment to ideas like success, fairness, pride, they're quite healthy. We tend to live a happier existence. I think that this idea is really, really profound.
它来自佛教。在佛教中，自我基本上是痛苦的根源。自我让我们忘记了我们存在于一个极其广阔、流动的生态系统中，与我们共同生存的还有其他同样拥有各自的复杂性、故事和价值的有灵众生，而我们的自我却以一种极不自然且有害的方式将我们置于所有人之上。因此，当我探索这个主题时，我读到了“清醒斯多葛学派”（the mindful stoic）写的一篇精彩文章，其中讨论了无我（anata或no self）的概念，这在佛教中相当受欢迎。基本上，这种无我的观点表明我们周围一切事物的结合体。我们一直在变，
It's very freeing to just exist and watch yourself evolve and detach from all the heavy stuff that we opt into and just understand that you and everyone around you is equal, is hopefully in harmony and are connected. What happens when ego rules? Well, that becomes a problem. Ego is wanting to separate you from this humility and this understanding of connectedness with other human beings. Ego is also always going to be a part of you.
没有任何事能让我们比任何其他人更特别。我们所做的任何事，都不能将所有的功劳全归于自己。我们基本上只是世界体验自身的一种方式。当我们尊重这一原则时，我们对成功、公平、骄傲等观念的执念就会变得相当健康。我们往往会过上更幸福的生活。我认为这个想法真的、真的很深刻。
Now, that's something that I probably should have stayed before. The idea and the existence of ego was not the problem. It's when it's allowed to rule and when essentially we are off balance. Here are some signs that that is occurring. Here are some signs that, you know, you kind of need to humble yourself. The first red flag is that, quite simply, you always need to be right and you struggle with any form of criticism even when it's valid. Specifically, I'm talking about instances or individuals who feel quite threatened when someone disagrees with them and has a very hard time admitting that they're wrong. This often has quite a physical element to it. Someone disagrees with you. Someone argues back and
仅仅是存在着、看着自己进化，并摆脱我们选择接受的所有沉重的包袱，去理解你周围的每个人都是平等的，有望处于和谐之中并且是相互联系的，这非常令人解放。当自我统治时会发生什么？好吧，这就成了问题。自我想要将你与这种谦逊以及对与其他人类相互联系的理解隔离开来。自我也将永远是你的一部分。
you feel that hot flush, maybe even that rage or that anger that you are being disrespected. When, if you dug a little bit deeper, you would see that you have more to learn in this moment than to be hurt by. And you are actually hurting yourself more by being defensive. because these experiences of criticism, of feedback, of disagreement, they're actually learning moments, they're teaching moments, their opportunities, they're a doorway to more knowledge about the world and to seeing things differently. But when your ego is in control, you never are able to see them that way. This also links to the second observation or sign that your ego was out of control, which is that you take everything personally, including others' reactions,
现在，这是我可能早该说的话。自我的概念和存在并不是问题所在。问题在于当它被允许统治，并且本质上我们失去平衡时。以下是这种情况正在发生的一些迹象。以下是一些迹象，表明你知道自己需要放低姿态了。第一个危险信号是，很简单，你总是需要正确，你很难接受任何形式的批评，即使批评是合理的。具体来说，我指的是那些当有人不同意他们的观点时会感到受到威胁、并且极其难以承认自己错误的情况或个人。这通常带有相当强的身体反应。有人不同意你的观点。有人反驳你，
and others bad days. I'm going to call myself out there. That woman who got upset at me for, I guess, walking in her way, she was entitled to have that reaction. But my reaction to her reaction, that was ego. Because I was interpreting what could have been a neutral comment or action as an attack, as a slight, and I was allowing it to infiltrate deeper than it was intended to
你感到了那种面红耳热，甚至可能是那种被不尊重而引发的狂怒或愤怒。然而，如果你稍微深挖一下，你就会发现在这个时刻，你有更多的东西要去学习，而不是去受到伤害。而且你通过采取防御姿态，实际上是在更多地伤害自己。因为这些批评、反馈和分歧的经历，实际上是学习的时刻，是教导的时刻，是机遇，它们通往更多关于世界的知识以及以不同方式看待事物的通。但当你的自我处于控制之中时，你永远无法以这种方式看待它们。这也与第二种观察结果或迹象有关，即你的自我失控了，那就是你把所有事情都个人化了，包括别人的反应，
or that it needed to. Therefore, kind of ruining my day. The thing is, is that we are, of course, the center of our own universe. We can only see through our own mind's eye. We can only experience the world through our senses from our perspective. That makes it difficult sometimes to empathize with others. But empathy is also an incredibly unique and important human quality. And if you are devoid of that or if you are detached from it, it makes you hard to be around.
以及别人糟糕的日子。我要在这里自我检讨一下。那个因为我挡了她的路而生气的女人，她有权做出那样的反应。但面对她的反应，我的反应，那就是自我（ego）。因为我把本可能是一个中性的评论或行动解读为一种攻击、一种轻蔑，并且我任由它渗透得比原本打算的要深，或者比需要的要深，因此，有点毁了我的好心情。事实是，我们当然是自己宇宙的中心。我们只能通过自己的心眼去观察。我们只能从自己的视角通过感官去体验世界。这有时让人很难对他人产生同理心。但同理心同样是一种极其独特且重要的人类品质。如果你缺乏同理心，或者你与它脱节，就会让人很难与你相处。
And it makes it makes it harder for you to be happy. The third red flag, if your ego is unruly, you are craving validation and recognition, and you are constantly in what I call a more, more, more mindset. So the more, more, more mindset is basically a mindset where we are never entirely content or happy with what we have. Now, humans by nature, we actually exist according to something called the hedonistic treadmill. Essentially what this term describes is this thought or theory. that you cannot be happy all the time and that no matter what good things happen in your life,
这让人很难感到快乐。第三个红灯信号是，如果你的自我意识不受控制，你就会渴望认可和赏识，并陷入我所说的“越多越好”的心态中。所以，“越多越好”的心态基本上是一种让我们永远无法对现有的一切感到完全满足或快乐的心态。从天性上讲，人类其实是按照所谓的“享乐跑步机”来生活的。这个词基本上描述了这样一种想法或理论：你不可能一直都快乐，无论你的生活中发生什么好事，
what amazing successes you achieve, you are always going to return to quite a neutral point. Now that is healthy. It's very healthy. You cannot be at either extreme end of our emotion spectrum, either extreme surprise, joy, excitement or extreme misery for too long. It's a healthy thing to be somewhere in the middle. But if you, if your ego is, you, you know, if you haven't humbled yourself, you just cannot, you cannot make peace with the fact that at times, you will not receive recognition, you will not receive validation, people will not be thinking about you, people will not be praising you. That means that not only are you never happy with what you have, but you constantly feel this
取得多么惊人的成功，你最终总会回到一个相当中立的状态。这其实很健康。这非常健康。你不可能长时间处于情绪谱系的极端，无论是极端的惊讶、喜悦、兴奋，还是极端的痛苦。处于中间状态是一种健康的表现。但是如果你，如果你的自我没有受到约束，你知道的，如果你没有学会谦逊，你就根本无法接受这样一个事实：有时你不会得到认可，你不会得到赞赏，人们不会把注意力放在你身上，人们不会赞美你。这意味着，你不仅对拥有的一切从不满足，而且你还会不断感受到这种
pressure to push and strive harder and to bring the spotlight back onto you, which is unnatural. You also may compare yourself constantly, whether it's status, looks, success, popularity, you're always measuring your worth by someone else's. I always give this analogy, and I think I gave it in a recent rerun episode, but we have to remember comparison. It's a circle, not a ladder. There is not someone who is objectively the happiest person or the best person or the most successful person in this world. and there is probably not a person who wants for nothing.
强迫自己去拼搏、去奋斗、去把聚光灯重新吸引到自己身上的压力，这是很不自然的。你也可能会不断地将自己与他人进行比较，无论是地位、外表、成功还是受欢迎程度，你总是用别人的标准来衡量自己的价值。我总是打这样一个比方，我想我在最近重播的一期节目里也说过，但我们必须记住比较。它是一个圆圈，而不是梯子。这个世界上并没有一个人客观上就是最快乐的人、最好的人或最成功的人，也可能没有一个人是无欲无求的。
Even if they are someone who is trying very hard for that, even if they are someone who is very spiritually disciplined, all of us feel jealous and envious at times. But you might be looking at someone thinking, why don't I have what they have, whilst they're looking at someone else who is looking at you. And what you don't appreciate is that this is a circle, this is a cycle. And if you continue to constantly compare and ruminate and feel,
即使他们是一个非常努力追求这一点的人，即使他们是一个在精神上非常有纪律的人，我们所有人有时都会感到嫉妒和艳羡。但你可能会看着某人想，为什么我没有他们拥有的东西，而他们正看着另一个看着你的人。而你没有意识到的是，这是一个圆圈，这是一个循环。如果你继续不断地比较、反刍并感到，
miserable about what you don't have, you miss out on a lot of what you do. I think we're up to the sixth sign now that your ego is out of control, and that is that you need to always be in control. Letting others lead or not having the final say, it can make you feel very uncomfortable and anxious and uncertain, whether that is, you know, the need to control the itinerary for the group trip, not being able to work in a team, craving alone time because it's easier to not think about others, that has a real consequence for our relationships. We cannot let our grip up over our life and over our interactions with others. I will say some people are what we call type A individuals. Some people are just like that. They're older children. They're naturally leaders. But the
对你没有的东西感到痛苦，你就会错过很多你真正拥有的东西。我想我们现在已经说到自负失控的第六个迹象了，那就是你必须时刻保持控制。让别人主导或者自己没有最终决定权，会让你感到非常不舒服、焦虑和不确定，无论是需要掌控集体旅行的行程，无法在团队中工作，还是渴望独处，因为不考虑别人会更容易，这对我们的关系产生了真正的负面影响。我们不能死死抓着生活和与他人的互动不放。我得说，有些人被称为A型人格。有些人天生就是这样。他们是家里的老大。他们天生就是领导者。但
distinction is the ability to compromise without emotional distress and discomfort. It's not, you know, some individuals will naturally take charge because they're just very good at but if they were invited to not take charge, they wouldn't have this visceral sense or need to reinstate themselves at the center of everything. They are able to say, yes, someone else might not do this the way that I will do it. Doesn't mean it's not a worthwhile valid way. Doesn't mean I can't be happy with whatever they produce. A couple more signs, you feel threatened by others' success and you also struggle to apologize. Two big ones that I've actually, I've seen in people's behavior before and they're not that pleasant. All of this turns us into, you may have guessed it, a deeply unhappy person,
区别在于是否具备在没有情绪困扰和不适的情况下妥协的能力。并不是说，你知道的，有些人天生就会挑大梁，因为他们真的很擅长，但如果他们被邀请不要挑大梁，他们就不会产生这种内心的感觉或需要，非要把自己重新置于所有事情的中心。他们能够说，是的，别人做这件事的方式可能和我做的不一样。但这并不意味着这不是一个有价值、有效的方法。并不意味着无论他们做出什么成果，我都无法感到高兴。还有几个迹象，你对别人的成功感到受到威胁，你也很难向别人道歉。这两个大问题我其实以前在别人的行为中看到过，它们并不是那么令人愉快。所有这一切都会让我们变成，你可能已经猜到了，一个非常不快乐的人，
but also a self-conscious person and someone who was not a good friend, not a good partner, not a good child, not a good sibling or colleague. That last point is very important because being in community requires people to decenter themselves. I read a similar quote recently that being in community requires inconvenience. A lot of people talk about loneliness these days. They talk about how it's difficult to make friends, difficult to be seen. But if you think you are the most important person in the world, you are not going to be able to tolerate the inconvenience
但同时也是一个过于自我意识过剩的人，一个不是好朋友、好伴侣、好孩子、好兄弟姐妹或好同事的人。最后一点非常重要，因为融入社群需要人们将自己边缘化。我最近读到一句类似的话，融入社群需要带来不便。现在很多人都在谈论孤独。他们谈论交友有多难，被看见有多难。但如果你认为自己是世界上最重要的人，你就无法容忍这种不便，
and sometimes the difficulty of having to compromise and be around other people. Think about it. Being a good partner means being able to admit you're wrong. Means compromise means losing control sometimes. means doing things that aren't always what you want to do, but that are what's best for the team. If you are not tuned into that fact that your preferences and lifestyle don't matter more than anyone else's,
有时还要忍受妥协和与其他人相处的困难。想想看。做一个好的伴侣意味着能够承认自己错了。意味着妥协，意味着有时失去控制。意味着做的事情并不总是你想做的事，而是对团队最有利的事。如果你没有意识到这样一个事实，即你的偏好和生活方式并不比任何其他人的更重要，
that is going to be a hard dynamic. Any relationship is going to be difficult to sustain. Now, we know relationships are one of our main predictors of happiness. Studies have proved this again and again and again. Actually, one of the longest longitudinal studies on happiness in the world found that positive relationships make you live longer, make you more pleasant, make you happier, make you more satisfied with your life. So if ego is costing you those relationships, it's also costing you your happiness. If you are lonely, if you don't have those meaningful connections,
这将是一种艰难的动态关系。任何关系都将难以维持。现在，我们知道关系是我们幸福的主要预测指标之一。研究一次又一次地证明了这一点。事实上，世界上关于幸福时间最长的纵向研究之一发现，积极的人际关系能让你活得更久，让你更愉快，让你更快乐，让你对生活更满意。因此，如果自我意识让你失去了这些关系，它也剥夺了你的快乐。如果你感到孤独，如果你没有那些有意义的联系，
what do you have? Success, accomplishment, knowing you're right, like none of that really means anything. And it reminds me of now a very famous interview between, I think it was Benny Blanco and Elena Gomez where he basically says like what do I have to achieve by being right like an angry girlfriend and not much else for what and that's a mature man right there he has understood the cost of his ego and it's something that a lot of us are yet to recognize it may not come as a surprise as well that ego and narcissism go hand in hand narcissism as a term is often misused a lot what we are talking about today is narcissism as a trait, not narcissistic personality disorder, not narcissism in a medical setting, narcissism as a trait that we all have some of.
你还剩下什么？成功、成就、证明自己是对的，这些其实都没有什么意义。这让我想起了一个现在非常著名的采访，采访对象好像是贝尼·布兰科和赛琳娜·戈麦斯，他在采访中基本上说，像一个生气的女朋友一样通过证明自己是对的，我到底能得到什么，其实没得到多少，为了什么？那才是一个成熟的男人，他已经明白了自我意识的代价，这是我们许多人尚未认识到的。自我意识和自恋相辅相成，这一点可能也不足为奇。自恋这个词经常被滥用，我们今天讨论的是作为一种特质的自恋，而不是自恋型人格障碍，不是医学意义上的自恋，而是我们每个人身上都有一点点的自恋特质。
Like any trait in this world, any personality trait, like all of us have a little inch of it. When you are high in narcissism as a trait, as some people naturally are, basically you cannot see anyone else's point of view because you see everything as a mirror of yourself or something to take advantage of. You must find yourself competent, successful, attractive, desirable, intelligent, or else. What does that also sound like? It also sounds like a dysregulated ego. Now this means that we can basically understand ego and pride and a lack of humility
就像这个世界上的任何特质一样，任何性格特质，我们所有人身上都有那么一点。当你身上的自恋特质很高时，就像有些人天生那样，基本上你无法看到任何其他人的观点，因为你把一切都看作是你自己的镜子或是可以利用的东西。你必须觉得自己能干、成功、迷人、渴望、聪明，否则就会如何。这听起来又像什么？它听起来也像是一个失调的自我。现在这意味着我们基本上可以通过审视自恋以及审视其根源，来理解自我、骄傲以及缺乏谦逊。
by examining narcissism as well and examining the origins of it. And a study published by NYU in 2021 has found that narcissism is driven primarily by a deep-rooted sense of self-hatred. in this study individuals who are higher on traits associated with narcissism they were typically quite emotionally vulnerable and felt quite emotionally i don't like the term weak uh out in the open maybe that's also where our inflated ego comes from it comes from a desire to protect ourselves because perhaps we don't feel great or feel good enough deep down so we counteract that by puffing out our chest, we counteract that by turning up the entitlement so we don't have to uncover unfortunate truths about how we really feel about ourselves. There is a great article that was
纽约大学在2021年发表的一项研究发现，自恋主要是由一种根深蒂固的自我厌恶感驱动的。在这项研究中，那些与自恋相关的特质得分较高的人，通常在情感上相当脆弱，并且觉得自己很脆弱——我不喜欢“软弱”这个词——暴露在外，也许这就是我们膨胀的自我意识的来源。它来自于保护自己的欲望，因为也许我们在内心深处感觉并不好，或者觉得自己不够好，所以我们通过挺起胸膛来抵消这一点，我们通过提高优越感来抵消这一点，这样我们就不必去揭开关于我们对自己真实感受的不幸真相。有一篇很棒的文章
published by the Society of Personality and Social Psychology and it's titled A Narcissistic People Happy and it looked at the mood of over 2,000 individuals who had narcissistic personality disorder and it found that a lot of them were quite miserable, especially when they felt that they were constantly in competition with others or had some rivalry. They were less happy than the average person. In fact, they reported greater life dissatisfaction, greater relationship dissatisfaction, greater sense of accomplishment when it came to their achievements.
由人格与社会心理学学会发表，题为“自恋的人快乐吗？”，它调查了2000多名患有自恋型人格障碍的个体的心理状态，发现他们中的许多人相当痛苦，特别是当他们觉得自己在与他人不断竞争或存在某种对抗时。他们比普通人更不快乐。事实上，他们报告了更高的生活不满感、更高的关系不满感，以及在取得成就时更少获得成就感。
Now, perhaps I've gone too far here because, you know, this isn't to suggest that we are all narcissists if we can relate to our ego taking over, but maybe when that happens, this gives us a clue as to what our ego thinks, it's protecting us from, the expected unhappiness, the insecurity, the jealousy, the poor self-esteem that may come to the surface if we don't keep trying to inflate ourselves and prove ourselves. Maybe, unlike narcissism, ego is quite protective, and ego is the result of something quite squishy and soft and delicate inside of us that feels a bit bruised.
现在，也许我这里有点说得太过了，因为，你知道的，这并不是说如果我们能与自我意识占据上风产生共鸣，我们就都是自恋狂，但也许当这种情况发生时，它给了我们一个线索，让我们明白我们的自我意识认为它在保护我们免受什么侵害：如果我们不不断地膨胀自己、证明自己，可能会浮出水面的预期痛苦、不安全感、嫉妒和糟糕的自尊。也许，与自恋不同，自我意识具有相当强的保护作用，自我意识是我们内心某种非常脆弱、柔软和娇嫩、感觉有点受挫的东西的结果。
So this brings me to my next question. Why do we sometimes feel so entitled for seemingly no reason? What spikes ego? We're going to take a short break here and then I'm going to return with a few explanations. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building
这让我想到了下一个问题。为什么有时我们感觉自己理所应当，却似乎毫无理由？是什么刺激了自我？我们在这里稍作休息，然后我会带着几个解释回来。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中建立精神坚韧、体能和
resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Heart Radio app,
恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。听“2%”。在I-Heart Radio应用上搜索TWO%，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
苹果播客，或者无论你在哪里收听播客。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在本期节目中，我们对此进行探讨，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目，所以我开始看到了一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病，所以。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
感谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎收听我的新播客“从艰难中学习”，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安，瑞安，有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现作为一个好人很重要，当你来到世上。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任层面的东西。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。和我一起，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话，
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle,
“从艰难中学习”。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“从艰难中学习”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭诉讼，
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
来证明真相。你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吧？我对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Grega lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷加·莱斯利，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱情陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So you've snapped. You feel like a terrible, horrible, no good person. Why is that the case? Why was humility not on your side in that moment? Firstly, and this one is probably the most likely case for those of us in our 20s, you've just got a lot on your plate right now. You're irritated, you're overworked, you're overstretched, and your capacity to monitor and mediate your emotions and reign in your ego.
在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“爱情陷阱”播客。所以你崩溃了。你觉得自己是一个可怕的、糟糕的、一无是处的人。为什么会这样？为什么那一刻谦逊没有站在你这边？首先，对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说，这可能是最常见的情况，你最近手头有很多事情。你很烦躁，过度劳累，过度透支，你监控和调节情绪以及控制自我意识的能力。
It just isn't there right now. When we're in that survival overextending mode, we are naturally more tense and more defensive. And that defensiveness extends to our sense of, self and self-worth. This really does come down to emotional regulation and the fact that this becomes harder at these points in our lives, these tension points, lots of deadlines, moving house, relationship problems that bleed into work, bleed into friendships. It's somewhat of a cruel cycle. You know, we need emotional regulation to manage stress, but when we're stressed, it becomes
现在根本不存在。当我们处于那种生存和过度透支的模式时，我们天生更加紧张和防备。这种防备延伸到了我们的自我感和自我价值感。这确实归结于情绪调节，以及在生命的这些时间点（这些紧张点，大量的 deadlines、搬家、渗入工作的感情问题、渗入友谊的问题）这变得更加困难的事实。这在某种程度上是一个残酷的循环。你知道，我们需要情绪调节来管理压力，但当我们感到压力时，它就会变得
harder to regulate any form of rational thinking, meaning we can't navigate our emotions or our ego properly. The solution here is to find a tiebreaker or reroute, which means simply stop doing what you've been doing all along that obviously isn't working thinking that it's going to work. Stop pushing yourself even further. Stop being cruel to yourself to rein in your ego. Try something new here. Specifically, I think if you want to control your ego, you need to slow down and be more intentional about your thoughts but also your actions. What can you do to calm. down your nervous system and fill that emotional cup back up so that it can restore a healthy level of ego. Rest, it's physically important. It's also mentally important and it's emotionally
更难调节任何形式的理性思维，这意味着我们无法正确地引导我们的情绪或自我。这里的解决方案是找到一个决胜局或重新规划路线，这意味着干脆停止你一直在做的、显然行不通却又以为行得通的事情。停止进一步逼迫自己。停止用残酷的方式对待自己来控制你的自我。在这里尝试一些新的东西。具体来说，我认为如果你想控制你的自我，你需要放慢脚步，对你的想法以及行动更有意识。你能做些什么来让你的神经系统平静下来，把那个情绪杯子重新填满，以便它能恢复健康的自我水平？休息，这在生理上很重要。在心理上也很重要，在情感上也同样
important. If you are finding that you are at the end of your tether and that you feel abrasive, entitled, prideful, I really sometimes think it's just a matter of exhaustion. The other reason that our ego can become unruly as unmet needs or insecurities. When we feel inadequate, as we said, overlooked, insecure, our ego steps in to compensate and it builds a false sense of superiority to kind of protect and guard our self-worth. Validation addiction is another term that we should be across here as well. It refers to essentially an unnatural dependency on praise, attention, and success. The ego begins to expect reward, expect applause or admiration as a baseline, not as a bonus. A 2020 study found that validation addiction is very common amongst not just high achievers,
重要。如果你发现自己已经精疲力竭，感到尖酸刻薄、自以为是、自负，我有时真的觉得这只是一种精疲力竭的表现。自我变得难以管束的另一个原因是没有得到满足的需求或不安全感。正如我们所说，当我们感到不够优秀、被忽视、缺乏安全感时，我们的自我就会介入以进行补偿，并建立一种虚假的安全感和优越感，以此来保护和维护我们的自我价值。对认可成瘾是我们在这里也应该了解的另一个词。它基本上是指对赞扬、关注和成功的非自然依赖。自我开始期待回报，把掌声或赞赏当作底线，而不是额外的奖励。2020年的一项研究发现，对认可成瘾不仅在追求卓越的人当中非常普遍，
but what they call ultra high achievers. A whole new level. And what they tended to find was that these individuals were generally not satisfied by any accomplishment that didn't come with praise. they could produce their best work yet. They could run a sub two-hour marathon. I don't even think that's humanly possible. But, you know, they could paint the next Sistine Chapel.
而且在他们所说的超级追求卓越的人当中也很常见。一个全新的水平。他们倾向于发现的是，这些人通常不会对任何没有伴随赞美成就感到满意。他们可以创作出他们迄今为止最好的作品。他们可以跑出两小时以内马拉松的成绩。我甚至认为这在人类身上是不可能的。但是，你知道，他们可以画出下一座西斯廷教堂。
But if there was no praise, it wouldn't be worth it to them. Everything is based on external recognition. And when investigating this, they did a little bit more digging, a little bit more searching. They found that it typically begins around the age of between 12 to 17. So prime teen years around puberty when our senses. identity is in a real growth formative period, but also when we are quite young, we're learning what our worth is. We're learning essentially the guidebook by, you know, by which we're going to judge ourselves. And if during that time, what you are absorbing from your environment, from your
但如果没有赞美，对他们来说就不值得。一切都建立在外部认可的基础之上。当调查这一点时，他们进行了更多的挖掘，更多的搜索。他们发现这种情况通常始于12岁到17岁之间。也就是青春期前后，当我们的认同感处于一个真正成长的形成期，而且当我们还很年轻的时候，我们正在学习我们的价值是什么。我们基本上在学习指南，以此来评判我们自己。如果在那个时期，你从你的环境中吸收的是，从你的
caregivers, from your community, from your environment is you are only worth something if you can produce good output and if you are being praised for that output. and based on something that we can see physically, that's going to really fuck with your sense of self-concept. And it's going to ensure that the older you get, the higher that baseline for validation becomes until it's unruly, unmanageable and cannot be met. Now, those are some very high-level reasons
照顾者、从你的社区、从你的环境中吸收的是，只有当你能产生好的产出，并且因为这种产出而受到赞扬时，你才是有价值的。而且是基于我们可以物理看到的东西，这将会极大地搞砸你的自我概念感。并且它将确保你年龄越大，对认可的基线要求就越高，直到它变得难以管束、无法管理且无法满足。现在，这些是一些非常高层面的原因
why we may be called to humble ourselves and why we need to embrace the power of humility. Let's now talk about exactly how to get there. Now let's just say one more time, you're never going to eliminate ego. We've talked about ego a lot this episode and perhaps I've done a bad job and painting it as this very villainous evil thing. It's not a bad thing. It's not harmful. Having a healthy level of ego allows you to set boundaries, allows you to recognize what you do and don't deserve, allows you to work hard, have ambitions, maintain a stable sense of self. We don't want to give any of that up. And I also don't want you to feel shame at being envious
为什么我们可能会被呼唤去保持谦逊，以及为什么我们需要拥抱谦逊的力量。现在让我们来谈谈具体如何做到这一点。现在让我们再说一遍，你永远不会消除自我。我们在这一集里谈了很多关于自我的内容，也许我把它描绘成一个非常反派的邪恶东西，这并不是一件坏事。它不是一件坏事。它不是有害的。拥有健康的自我水平可以让你设定界限，让你认识到你应得的和不应得的，让你努力工作，有雄心壮志，保持稳定的自我意识。我们不想放弃这一切。我也不希望你因为感到羡慕
or jealous or accidentally rude or mean. And I don't want you to think that just because you have acted that way in the past, that that is always who you are going to be and how you are going to feel. I say this a lot. You simply cannot hate yourself into being a better person. It doesn't work that way because if you truly think you are awful and curse and whatever else is running through your mind, you have no incentive to improve because this all feels very set in stone. Your shame and self-awareness, it's gotten you to this very important point. You have recognized that perhaps something is off. That's a good thing. Now it's time to focus on the mindset shifts that are available to you to get you out of this downward ego spiral.
或嫉妒或不小心粗鲁或刻薄而感到羞耻。我也不希望你认为，仅仅因为你过去那样做过，你就会永远是那样的人，就会一直有这种感觉。我经常这样说。你根本无法通过憎恨自己来让自己成为一个更好的人。这不管用，因为如果你真的认为自己很糟糕、很可恶或者脑子里充斥着其他不好的想法，你根本没有动力去改进，因为这一切感觉都太根深蒂固了。你的羞耻感和自我意识，已经让你走到了这个非常重要的关头。你已经认识到也许有什么不对劲。这是一件好事。现在是时候专注于你可以做出的心态转变，以此帮助你摆脱这个不断恶化的自我螺旋。
humility is also just such a great asset to have. Humility makes you more attractive. It makes you more desirable as a romantic partner. Humility is a strong predictor of relationship satisfaction, but also relationship length and sustainability. It makes you a more desirable employee. And it also means that people feel more comfortable around you because you're less defensive and judgmental. I know that confidence and arrogance and thinking that you're the shit, like that's, some people are going to confuse that with having a strong sense of self and knowing your worth. I don't necessarily think that when it gets to the level where you are instinctually judging or thinking cruelly of other people, I don't think that that is what we're talking about. We're talking about the balance. So in order to get back to that balance point, the first thing I need you to do is call yourself out. Call yourself out for those moments like the one I experienced the other day where you just behaved in a bad manner. Your instinct was ugly, no matter how much control you had over it or not,
谦逊也是一项非常棒的资产。谦逊让你更有吸引力。作为浪漫伴侣，它让你更受欢迎。谦逊是关系满意度的一个强大预测指标，也是关系长度和可持续性的预测指标。它让你成为一个更受欢迎的员工。这也意味着人们在你身边会感到更舒适，因为你的防备心更低，也更不容易评判他人。我知道自信、傲慢以及认为自己很了不起，有些人会把这与拥有强烈的自我意识和了解自己的价值混为一谈。我不一定认为，当它达到你本能地评判或残酷地看待其他人的程度时，我不认为这就是我们在谈论的。我们在谈论的是平衡。因此，为了回到那个平衡点，我需要你做的第一件事就是直面自己。为那些时刻直面自己，比如我前几天经历的那种时刻，你只是表现得很糟糕。你的本能是丑陋的，不管你对它有多大程度的控制，
it was coming from a place that was not being taken care of. People aren't always going to call you out for your bad behavior. In fact, you know, you could get to a point where even if they did, you would still not believe them. And that would result in reputational and interpersonal damages or consequences. It will result in relationship failure and breakdown because you have gotten to a point where you just think they're a hater or you think that they're, you know, criticizing you. So when you notice that your behavior is not what you want it to be, I want you to say it out loud, that's not okay. I want you to ask yourself, why did I say that? I want you to pull your head in. Remember, bad, mean, cruel thoughts, they come from you. That also means that a
它来自于一个没有被照顾好的地方。人们并不总是会指出你的不良行为。事实上，你知道，你可能会达到这样一种程度：即使他们真的指出了，你仍然不会相信他们。这将导致声誉和人际关系的损害或后果。它会导致关系的失败和破裂，因为你已经到了这样一种地步：你只觉得他们是个嫉妒者，或者你觉得他们是在批评你。所以，当你注意到你的行为不是你所希望的那样时，我希望你大声说出来，这不对。我希望你问问自己，我为什么要这么说？我希望你收敛一下。记住，糟糕、卑鄙、残酷的想法，它们来自于你。这也意味着
a better thought can come from you as well. You are capable and able and allowed to have mean thoughts that you don't particularly like or prideful thoughts and then take that thought, examine it, give it a kiss and replace it with something even better. Secondly, if you are ready to embrace the power of humility, don't do a gratitude list. Commit to a contribution list, a list of things that you have done for others. I will say gratitude and huge. humility, a very healthy match and studies do find they're mutually reinforcing. That means the more you feel one, the more you feel the other. But I think we can take it a step further and really start to reflect and make our priority what we are doing for other people and our community. And if you
更好的想法也可以来自于你。你有能力、有资格并且被允许产生那些你特别不喜欢或自负的想法，然后拿走那个想法，审视它，给它一个吻，并用更好的东西取而代之。其次，如果你准备好拥抱谦逊的力量，不要做什么感恩清单。承诺写一份奉献清单，列出你为他人做过的事情。我要说的是，感恩和巨大的谦逊是非常健康的搭配，研究也发现它们是相互强化的。这意味着你对一者的感受越多，对另一者的感受也就越多。但我认为我们可以更进一步，真正开始反思，并把我们为其他人以及我们的社区所做的事情作为优先事项。如果你
have a contribution list, I think this makes this more of a focus for you to be putting things on that list as regularly as possible. De-centre yourself by doing something selfless. As self-ful, as selfless as any act can really be, but something that is not primarily for you. I think our issue as a society, specifically in a highly individualistic society, is that we are taught, again, that we're at the center of our own universe and that we should always look out for ourselves first. We focus on what makes us special, what we need, when we have more than plenty. We have so much more than we need. And because of our obsession with just gaining more, gaining more praise, wealth, whatever it is, we've lost this sense of interconnectedness.
有一份奉献清单，我认为这会使你更关注这一点，尽可能经常地把事情列入这份清单。通过做一些无私的事情来淡化自我。尽管任何行为都可以说是无私的，但做一些并非主要为了你自己的事情。我认为我们作为一个社会的社会问题，特别是在高度个人主义的社会中，我们被教导，再次强调，我们是自己宇宙的中心，我们应该永远首先照顾好自己。我们专注于是什么让我们与众不同，我们需要什么，当我们拥有远超所需的充足资源时。我们拥有的远远超过我们的需求。正是因为我们对获得更多、获得更多赞誉、财富或无论什么的痴迷，我们失去了这种相互关联的意识。
You are going to do better if your neighbor is doing better, if your friends are doing better, if the people around you feel supported. So if you are feeling gross about yourself, if you are engaging in too much self-pity, if your ego is dominating, it is time to do something for someone else. And speaking of others, my third tip is to start noticing the most beautiful things about other people. My humility always goes down the drain when I start feeling bad about the world, when I start believing that everyone is cruel and mean and cold-hearted and therefore I have to only look after myself. That's especially hard these days with the news, with everything going on. I need to remind myself that humanity and other people are beautiful and that life is
如果你的邻居过得更好，如果你的朋友过得更好，如果你周围的人感到被支持，你就会过得更好。因此，如果你对自己的感觉很糟，如果你沉溺于过多的自我怜悯，如果你的自我占据了主导地位，是时候为别人做点什么了。说到其他人，我的第三个建议是开始注意到其他人身上最美丽的事物。当我开始对世界感觉不好，当我开始相信每个人都是残忍、卑鄙、冷酷无情的，因此我必须只照顾好自己时，我的谦逊总是烟消云散。如今有新闻和各种发生的事情，这尤其困难。我需要提醒自己，人性和其他人是美丽的，生命是
valuable and that we are all the same. Like I am no better than anyone else. There is good in everyone. And so I've started doing this walk slash run practice. In particular, I started doing it on my long run. So like every weekend, me and my friends go to Centennial Park in Sydney and we do like a couple of laps. It ends up being like 10 kilometers. And one day I forgot my headphones. And I was just in a bad mood. And I don't know, something had happened that week. And I was feeling like quite angry. Like, I don't know, people would like kind of get in my way and I'd be like, I was getting frustrated. And so, we were. And so, what I started doing is every single person that walked past me, I forced myself to notice something
宝贵的，我们都是一样的。就像我并不比任何人更好。每个人都有好的一面。所以我开始做这种步行加慢跑的练习。特别是，我开始在长跑时这样做。所以每个周末，我和我的朋友们都会去悉尼的百年公园，跑上几圈。最后大约是10公里。有一天我忘带耳机了。我当时心情很不好。而且不知道为什么，那周发生了些事情。我感觉相当生气。就像，我不知道，人们会挡住我的路，我会觉得，我开始感到沮丧。所以，我们当时就是这样。因此，我开始做的是，每一个从我身边走过的人，我都强迫自己去注意到
really beautiful about them. Something spectacular, something wonderful, something about their outfit that I liked, the color of their eyes, how beautiful they were walking, how kind they were to their dog, how they were noticing nature. Every single person got this hidden compliment from me. And it immediately made me feel that interconnectedness that those Buddhist philosophies and Buddhist principles want us to feel with other people. It dissented me from the narrative. It allowed me to reconnect and remember that you know, humanity is gorgeous and beautiful and that people are kind and that that is enough. I think we're going to talk a little bit more about the role of others here just for one second, which is, yes, we want to do things for others. We want to notice things about others. We also want
他们身上非常美丽的东西。一些壮观的、美妙的东西，他们服装中我喜欢的部分、他们眼睛的颜色、他们走路时多么美丽、他们对狗有多善良、他们是如何注意到大自然。每个人都从我这里得到了这个隐藏的赞美。它立刻让我感受到了那些佛教哲学和佛教原则希望我们与他人感受到的相互联系。它让我从叙事中淡化了自我。它让我重新连接并记住，你知道，人性是华丽而美丽的，人们是善良的，这就足够了。我想我们在这里还要多谈一点其他人的角色，只需一秒钟，那就是，是的，我们要为他人做事情。我们要注意到其他人的事物。我们还想要
to give credit publicly and thank others. You can celebrate yourself and you should. We're not saying not to do that. When it's your moment and good things are happening and you've worked hard for them, go off. You did that. Celebrate yourself. Buy yourself a freaking cake. Put some candles in it. Tell people. Self-promote. But you also have to notice when it's someone else's moment as well. We are not letting a scarcity mindset trick us into envy and into not raising others up because we think there is less room for us. There is room for everyone. Believe me, I know in a success obsessed society, we don't think there is, but you are going to get further ahead and you are going to have a happier life if you are getting ahead with others beside you, who you care about and whose careers and
公开给予赞誉并感谢他人。你可以庆祝自己，你也应该这样做。我们并不是说不要这样做。当属于你的时刻到来、美好的事情正在发生、你为之努力工作时，那就去庆祝吧。你做到了。庆祝你自己。给自己买个该死的蛋糕。在上面插上蜡烛。告诉别人。自我推销。但你也必须注意到当这也是别人的时刻。我们不会让稀缺心态诱使我们陷入嫉妒，也不会因为我们认为留给我们的空间变小而不去提升他人。每个人都有空间。相信我，我知道在一个痴迷于成功的社会里，我们不认为有空间，但如果你和那些你关心的人、那些其职业和
ambitions and goals are meaningful to you and who you can celebrate. Like none of this, life is worth nothing without community. Community is so valuable. Every single person, that you feel envious towards or jealous of because they have more than you or doing something better than you, that means that there is something you can learn from them. That means that they have cracked a code that you are still working on. And a kindness towards them is a kindness towards yourself, but it also just makes your life better. It makes everyone's life better to give credit publicly, to thank people, to praise people, to speak their names in crowded rooms, their opportunities.
雄心壮志和目标对你很重要并且你可以为之庆祝的人并肩前行，你会走得更远，你会拥有更快乐的生活。就像没有社区，生活就毫无价值。社区是如此宝贵。每一个让你感到羡慕或嫉妒的人，因为他们拥有比你更多的东西或者比你做得更好，这意味着有你可以从他们身上学习的东西。这意味着他们破解了你仍在努力破解的代码。对他们的善良就是对你自己的善良，但这也会让你的生活变得更好。公开给予赞誉、感谢人们、赞美人们、在拥挤的房间里说出他们的名字、为他们提供机会，会让每个人的生活变得更好。
Here's my little challenge for you. This week, I really want you to hype someone up that you envy, even when it feels unnatural. Now, that could be someone that you know, someone you, one of your co-workers, colleagues, classmates, whatever it is. I want you to speak their praises. It could literally be a celebrity, could literally be a social media influencer. Speak kindly about them. I mainly, what all these exercises are doing is basically,
这是我给你的小挑战。这周，我真的希望你为你嫉妒的人大肆宣传，即使这感觉很不自然。现在，那可以是你认识的人，你的一位同事、同僚、同学，无论是什么。我希望你赞美他们。这甚至可以是一个名人，可以是一个社交媒体网红。友善地谈论他们。我主要想说的是，所有这些练习基本上都在做的是，
pursuing humility by allowing you to see how wonderful other people are and that there is no world where anyone is worth more than someone else, where your needs, your desires, your goals are more important. We are really truly all equal and yes, your ego will sometimes get in the way of that humility. That is when you need to deliberately humble yourself. And that is where you need to understand that if you approach things with humility, if you remove yourself from the center of your own universe and you focus outwards, you are going to get more done because you aren't always trying to prove yourself. You are going to have more fun because you take life less seriously. You take yourself less seriously. You are going to appreciate your mistakes more.
通过让你看到其他人是多么精彩，以及没有任何一个世界里任何人的价值高于其他人，没有任何一个世界里你的需求、你的欲望、你的目标更加重要，来追求谦逊。我们真的都是平等的，是的，你的自我有时会阻碍这种谦逊。那是你需要刻意让自己谦逊的时候。这就是你需要明白的地方：如果你以谦逊的态度对待事情，如果你把自己从自己宇宙的中心移开并将注意力转向外部，你将会完成更多的事情，因为你不再总是试图证明自己。你会获得更多的乐趣，因为你不再把生活看得那么严肃。你不再把你自己看得那么严肃。你会更感激你的错误。
You are going to be a better person to be around. And you are actually going to gain more momentum towards your goals because this huge factor has been taken out of the equation. This huge factor being how you think your story looks to others. This huge factor being trying to impress others, trying to protect your sense of self, trying to avoid any hint of rejection or unfairness or dissatisfaction. When you take that as part of your life and you humble yourself and you say, I'm just going to accept what comes and I'm going to work hard and be kind. Like, I know it sounds simple, but that is truly every single major religion,
你会成为一个更好相处的人。你实际上会为你的目标获得更多的动力，因为这个巨大的因素已经从等式中被剔除了。这个巨大的因素就是你认为你的故事在别人眼里是什么样的。这个巨大的因素就是试图给别人留下深刻印象、试图保护你的自我意识、试图避免任何一丝拒绝、不公平或不满。当你把这作为你生活的一部分，并让自己谦逊并说，我只是要接受随之而来的事情，我要努力工作并保持善良。就像，我知道这听起来很简单，但这就是每一个主要宗教、
every single major philosophy will tell you that that is the equation for a satisfied life. So I hope that this episode has been persuasive for you. I understand that it's more philosophical than what we normally talk about, but I promise we have a jam-packed science-packed psychology episode coming to you next week. If you made it this far, hello, my loyal listeners. I want you to leave. what emoji should I choose today? I want you to leave a little banana emoji down below. I would also love it if you shared your thoughts about this episode, further questions, thoughts,
每一个主要哲学都会告诉你，这就是过上满意生活的公式。所以我希望这一集对你来说是有说服力的。我理解这比我们通常谈论的要更具哲学性，但我承诺我们下周会为你带来一集充满科学、充满心理学的节目。如果你听到了这里，你好，我忠实的听众们。我希望你留下——我今天应该选择什么表情符号？我希望你在下方留下一个小的香蕉表情符号。我也很乐意你分享你对这一集的想法、更多的问题、思考、
queries, qualms, maybe you disagree with something that I said. Maybe there was a point I didn't make. Please leave it below. This is obviously, I feel like every episode I make, I want it to be an ongoing discussion. And we can learn so much from each other. So yeah, don't feel afraid to share. Make sure you share this episode as well with someone who you think needs to hear it, Although I feel like that's kind of a read if you're like the power of humility and you send that to someone. But you never know. Maybe you and your friends or your family or your partner have that kind of relationship.
疑问、隐忧，也许你不同意我所说的话。也许有些观点我没有表达清楚。请在下方留言。这显然是——我觉得我制作的每一集，我都希望它是一个持续的讨论。我们可以从彼此身上学到很多东西。所以，是的，不要害怕分享。确保你也把这一集分享给你认为需要听到它的人，尽管我觉得如果你说“谦逊的力量”然后把它发给某人，这有点像是在暗示什么。但你永远不知道。也许你和你的朋友、家人或伴侣有那种关系。
Maybe it can be a subtle hint that they need to rain it in. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Make sure that you check out person in progress and make sure that you're following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
也许这可以是一个微妙的提示，让他们收敛一点。但直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。确保你查看“进行中的人”（person in progress），并确保你在 Instagram 上关注我，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。我们很快就会交谈。嘿，伙计们，你们好吗？欢迎收听 Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%.
进行诚实的对话，而在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the 8%. IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客 2% 中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。也就是 TWO percent，在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. You got your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在 iHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听 The Girlfriends, Trust Me, Babe。在 Look Back at it 播客上。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Pie. or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Look Back at it。这是一个 iHeart 播客，保证是真人制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。